[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
nächste woche sonntag ist schon
muttertag und ich habe muss ich dazu
sagen fast vergessen eine torte für
meinen kanal zu packen
zum glück habe ich mal der zuschauer
noch dran erinnert hier ist die torte es
gibt auch schon ein rezept in diesem
jahr das habe ich gestern auf dem
interspar kanal hochgeladen
da gibt es nämlich eine schachbrett orte
die sind auch richtig toll aus mit einer
ganz tollen spritztechnik hier habe ich
jetzt eine torte ohne vom doch meine
zuschauer durften nämlich abstimmen ob
mit oder ohne deswegen habe ich
kurzfristig den plan noch mal
umgeschmissen
ich habe hier eine 100 orte im inneren
die him back creme außen eine weiße
katze und hier eine ganz tolle
spachteltechnik und das ganze dann mit
früchten dekoriert die torte ist
wirklich super erfrischend freut sich
bestimmt auch die mama darüber ich muss
aber auch dazu sagen ich mag das ganze
jahr war ich glaube gar nicht so was
ganz besonderes meinte wenn ich zum
muttertag wackelt aber die freut sich
das ganze jahr über und trotzdem feiern
gemeinsam muttertag
ich bin elf autos hat acht jahren mit
familie und ich freue mich auch in form
ihrer memoiren später machen
ich zeige euch jetzt zuerst aber einmal
dem teig da habe ich nämlich eine röhre
masse du dies auch super einfach in der
herstellung und spencer locke für den
teig verwende ich 170 gramm weiche
butter 120 gramm puderzucker vom etwas
mangel extrakt 717 eiweiß mit prise salz
120 gramm normalen zucker 150 gramm mehl
zehn gramm gefriergetrocknete himbeeren
und bei bedarf noch etwas milch beim
rührteig ist es nur wichtig dass die
zutaten alles immer warm sind also die
mutter und auch die eier gebe ich zuerst
die butter in die rührschüssel da kommt
der puderzucker dazu und etwas von ihr
extrakt
jetzt kann ich die zutaten ich hier für
einige minuten cremig verrühren und wird
in der zwischenzeit in der zweiten
schlüssel des eiweiß mit dem salz steif
schlagen und dann den zucker ganz
langsam da zugeht
[Musik]
der schnee ist fest wenn er die schüssel
über kopf stellt und nichts darunter
tropf jetzt gebe ich zur weiß cremigen
butter massa noch langsam die eigelbe
mit dazu immer 1 1 nach dem anderen den
rest erledige ich jetzt mit dem
schneebesen ich kann jetzt nämlich
einfach das mehl nehmen
das habe ich vorher gesiebt und das
könnt ihr kurz unterheben
gemeinsam mit einem schlückchen milch
und die milch die darf auch nicht kalt
sein auch schön zimmermann
jetzt gebe ich noch nach und macht den
eischnee dazu und bei der klassischen
rohe masse brauchen auch gar kein
backpulver denn die luftigkeit die kommt
einmal durch die butter und einmal durch
den igh schnell
[Musik]
und ich gebe es hier noch die
gefriergetrockneten himbeeren dazu die
sind etwas anders als gefahren werden
denn die auch einfach keine feuchtigkeit
mehr drin
das heißt da zeigt der nestern auch
nicht
[Musik]
und gefriergetrocknete früchte bekommen
meist nur ganz schwer aber man kann in
die baby abteilung gehen da kauf ich zum
beispiel auch gerne gefriergetrocknete
sachen für ella unser mehr
und da gibt es auch eine ganz große
auswahl und die können wir eben auch
benutzen
jetzt will ich den teig in zwei
backformen ein mit 20 cm durchmesser
damit die torte schön hoch wird
ansonsten reicht für eine torte mit 24
zentimetern durchmesser
[Musik]
und dann einfach verstreichen und backen
und die backzeit kann ich jetzt nutzen
um schon mal die creme vorzubereiten
[Musik]
so erstelle ich jetzt die weiße ghana
schwer die brauche ich nämlich zu
isolieren der himba creme und natürlich
auch zum bestreichen der torte als
unterlage für den von dort für die
ghanaische nehme ich jetzt etwas sahne
und lasst sie auftauchen dafür ich dann
noch die weiße schokolade ein ungefähr
so lange bis eine geschmeidige masse
entsteht die ghanas muss beim abkühlen
einen teil lassen uns über nacht bei
raumtemperatur stehen und einen teil
habe ich jetzt im kühlschrank die frau
nämlich gleich jetzt mache ich die
himbeere creme
ich nehme dafür tief gefrorenen beeren
die habe ich jetzt bereits auftauen
lassen und lasse jetzt so lange in einem
topf einkaufen bis die flüssigkeit fast
komplett verdunstet ist das hin bei
kurier streiche ich jetzt noch durch ein
haarsieb so dass ich einfach keine kern
immer drinnen habe ich habe es eine
größere menge fruchtpüree gemacht einen
teil davon verwende ich jetzt für meine
creme und den recht springe ich einfach
ein zu häufig beim nächsten mal auch
wieder die hinweg geben ich sage euch
jetzt noch die übrigen zutaten für die
himba creme stadt heben beim könnt ihr
natürlich auch zum beispiel erdbeeren
verwenden für die himba creme verwende
ich 150 gramm vom himmel 400 gramm sahne
300 gramm fisch käse im doppel raum
stufe 100 gramm puderzucker und etwas
salat
das ganze könnte jetzt in einer schüssel
zu bereiten also hier rein das muss
natürlich ganz kalt jetzt schon sein
damit die sache nicht gewinnt dann der
frischkäse dazu da nehme ich immer den
frischkäse im doppel rahm stufe die
sahne dazu geht es nicht
und jetzt ruhig die zutaten schon mal
durch damit alles schön verbunden ist
gibt da noch sein apartment rein und
schlagt die creme steigt
[Musik]
die mich dir nach man richtig lecker
die creme stelle ich jetzt kurz in den
kühlschrank holen meine zwei tortenböden
raus die habe ich jetzt einfach bei
raumtemperatur kurz abkühlen lassen dann
aus der form herausgelöst und auf
abkühlt er gesetzt und so dann noch mal
für etwa eine halbe stunde ins
gefrierfach gestellt so kann ich jetzt
nämlich besser durchschneiden
[Musik]
jetzt kann die torte schon befüllt
werden mit der garage die habe ich jetzt
in einen spritzbeutel mit einer großen
loch thüle gefüllt mache ich jetzt eine
isolierung außen rum also ich spazieren
rand und der schützt dann den von dorf
vor der humber creme denn die
hinbekommen hat einfach zu viel
feuchtigkeit und würde denn von dort
auflösen und damit ich die torte gleich
besser führen kann und sie stabiler wird
sich einfach den tortenring aus warum
sie ihn fest da können dann nämlich auch
mit der creme direkt bis an den rand
gehen
[Musik]
wir kommen jetzt die creme rein und auf
diese weise fühle ich jetzt die gesamte
torte
[Musik]
die krämer perfekt reingepasst jetzt
noch der decke und ihr seht jetzt habe
ich einen richtig schönen geraten
abschluss kann jetzt seine torten retter
drauf geben
da wird die torte schon mal schön gerade
von den seiten und von oben so stelle
ich sie jetzt für drei bis vier stunden
in den kühlschrank ich mache jetzt
einfach über nacht und morgen wird
dekoriert da freut sich die mama jetzt
ist die torte schön kühl und ich kann
sie aus der form herauslösen und dann
mit der ganz schön glatt streichen
wir sagen ich mache gern in heißem
wasser rum sondern ich nehme einfach den
symbolen
jetzt bin ich viel schneller heiß muss
man noch aufpassen hier beim griff nicht
und dann kann man schön raus lösen
er kommuniziert bekannt
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich die restliche garage und
die streiche ich jetzt einmal an den
rand und an die oberfläche sodass die
torte schön glatt wird
[Musik]
sie trage ich am rand immer gerne
großzügig auf und dann ziehe ich es
gleich mit der karte ab so bekommt man
gleich einen schönen glatten rand
[Musik]
jetzt streicht sich etwas ganz auf die
oberfläche
da lege ich jetzt ein kickboard drauf
und es hat den gleichen durchmesser wie
die torte
[Musik]
einfach upside down also die torte kurz
stützen
[Musik]
den brand noch mal schön glatt ab 10 und
das geht jetzt auch besser weil ich alle
skateboard darunter habe und praktisch
am keyboard entlang diese palette erwägt
sehen kann
und jetzt noch die oberfläche glatt
streichen
die torte stelle jetzt kurz kühl dass
sie fest werden
und dann kommt auch das finish dass ich
hier noch die lücken ausfüllen und dann
komplett streichen
[Musik]
die restliche garage habe ich jetzt hier
noch und eigentlich wollte ich hatte die
torte mit von dort über zehn aber ich
habe eine umfrage auf instagram gemacht
und 80 haben für nein gestimmt mache
eine torte ohne von dort also trefflich
jetzt meine planung und mache seine ohne
stimme die restliche die habe ich
nochmal erhitzt in der mikrowelle geht
aber auch einen warmen wasserbad mit der
schönen streichfähig und wenn sie mal
ein bisschen gerinnt oder wenn sie so
ein bisschen fertig aussieht gibt
einfach noch mal heiße sahne dazu habe
ich eben auch gemacht ich glücklich mit
rein und dann verbindet sich alles gut
jetzt nehme ich ein bisschen
lebensmittel verpasste dann nehme ich
das eine die sehr ergiebig ist könnte
natürlich auch die von deco back nehmen
wir sind auch super
ich brauche so ein schönes dunkles
bäriges roth deswegen nehme ich jetzt
die ich hier und jetzt verrühren
jetzt nämlich die kanadisch die wir
jetzt gleich an der torte schön fest da
heißt es okay wenn sie jetzt ein
bisschen physiker ist aber wir können
sie auch gerne noch ein bisschen
abkühlen lassen und die streiche ich
jetzt nur hier unten an den rand ein
bisschen hoch letztere sind sie dann
fest wird und dann machen wir da so eine
schöne spachteltechnik
[Musik]
wenn dann die garage am rand ein
bisschen fester wird könnte einfach die
palette nehmen oder auf messen oder im
brotmesser zum beispiel und könnte es
einfach in eine richtung am besten so
hoch ziehen so wie es muss da eben haben
wird da könnte man auch zum beispiel die
farben mischen hell und dunkel mission
was euch besser gefällt
zusätzliche karte kurz um auf meine
platte hier oben kommen jetzt ganz viele
bunte früchte drauf ich habe hier schon
etwa im blaumann himbeeren und
brombeeren
aber ich schreibe natürlich auch noch
was zum muttertag drauf jetzt nehme ich
einfach einen tortenring einen bug ring
schnell stellte sich ein kleiner und
teller wird aber auch gehen dass wir
jetzt einfach im kreis markiert das ich
eben weiß bis wohin sich ungefähr
schreiben kann
[Musik]
so ganz leicht nur markieren sie ein
bisschen der markierung mit nämlich eine
zucker schrift die wähl ich jetzt in
schwarz ihr könnt aber auch eine andere
farbe nehmen
die muss man vorher gut durchkneten und
eine spitze wegschneiden und dann kann
man damit auch von dauer oder eben auch
auf garage und cremes schreiben
[Musik]
und die erdbeeren die schneide ich gerne
auf mit grün
wie sehen sie denn die hübsche aus jetzt
einfach schön die früchte und gerne zum
beispiel auch blumen wo habe ich die
tritsch welche blumen die kriegs humor
aber nur für bewegung
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr die
früchte auch gerne mit etwas verstand
ankleben
[Musik]
so sieht die torte angeschnitten aus und
ich muss sagen sie gefällt mir richtig
gut
der murat ist quatsch ok ich sag's euch
dieses er macht hat mir dazu er hat
verpasst habe ich die torte
angeschnitten habe
hmm lecker
die creme ist vor allem ein richtiger
hit richtig schön die die himbeer note
sagt man doch in bern oder der
himbeergeschmack ich habe es mit
frischkäse gemacht das ist mein favorit
jetzt schreiben bestimmt einige wieder
runter und ich möchte kein vorspiel sehe
ich nehme gerne was anderes ihr könnt
natürlich auch mascarpone oder quack zum
beispiel nehmen aber mit frischkäse das
ist schon so mein favorit und ich würde
auf jeden fall empfehlen die torte
genauso nach zu machen wie sie eben
rezept steht die weiße schokolade passt
nämlich auch perfekt dazu
ich wünsche euch und euren mamas einen
wunderschönen muttertag weil sie die
torte nach macht dann postet sie auf
instagram oder facebook damit diese noch
anschauen kann also viel spaß beim
nachbacken und bis zum nächsten mal
die müsst ihr probieren kommt
probiert mal
[Musik]
wollte ein stück mitnehmen da ist die
ganzen torten immer wir
[Musik]
das turnier wird hätte wird im november
doch eben noch viel zu klein
jetzt werden sie bald nur die
französische abitur studieren
ihr seid gemein
ja ich komme wieder schneider die torte
gleichsam es damals ja noch mit der
murat wird nicht erwachsen
[Gelächter]